nous passons à notre deuxième sujet
l'ancien ministre les républicains
frédéric lefebvre rallier à la
république en marche a déclenché une
très forte polémique en demandant une
commission d' enquête autour des
relations qui unissent le rassemblement
national
et s'il bat nancy banane c'est l'un des
inspirateurs de l'idéologie donald trump
l'inde est l'un des artisans de sa
victoire
aussi ils considèrent fait avec le feph
que
lorsqu'on nationale seront coupables de
haute trahison en ayant des liens avec
cet homme il ya donc une des
parlementaires qui demande d'ouverture
d'une enquête pour intelligence avec
l'ennemi
tout ça n'est pas tout à fait du goût
évidemment du parti de marine le pen et
notamment de jordan bardella qui est la
tête de liste aux élections européennes
il l'a dit ce matin à nos confrères de
sud radio pour lui on marche dans la
tête
est ce que vous vous rendez compte du
délire est ce que vous vous rendez
compte d'une intelligence avec l'ennemi
la queue on a effectivement et ai
rencontré le directeur de campagne de
donald trump et on est suspecté
d'intelligence avec l'ennemi avec les
est un métier qu une menace pour la
sécurité nationale
en réalité on voit que il la ficelle est
assez usés et que la majorité en reste
et qui n'a pu vraiment d'argument nous
opposer sur le fond puisque même loiseau
a vivement du mal à faire décoller sa
campagne et c'est de jeter des boules
puantes depuis depuis maintenant
quelques jours
alors commençons par donner la parole à
l'accusation
guillaume klossa vous avez écrit en
septembre dernier une tribune au canon
contre ce type banane qui s'appelait
ziff stib à nongo m c'était dans le
journal du dimanche
et vous parlez je cite d' attaques
insupportables de sa part et de volonté
de détruire l'union européenne alors ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
steve banane s'inscrit dans une
tradition qui n'est pas la tradition
l'état américain donc ce n'est pas un
ennemi d'état et c'est à partir de là
très difficile de mettre en oeuvre ce
que monsieur lefebvre a recommandé mais
ban s'inscrit dans une tradition qui est
financé par des fondations américaines
notamment la fondation héritage qui a eu
un département qui s'appelle le
département margaret thatcher et qui
chaque année depuis dix ou vingt ans
investit 10 millions d'euros pour
anéantir l'union européenne et trouver
les arguments des argumentaires pour
cela et monsieur ban est le digne
héritier de ces gens et les venues en
europe à l'été avec l'idée de rallier
tous les populismes de créer un vaste
mouvement populiste et la vérité c'est
que monsieur ban même par les populistes
on le dit monsieur banane taisez vous et
rentrez chez vous même si même les
populistes et moi je trouve que banane
fait pschitt et que c'est un grand
honneur ou jeu
duy de lui consacrait autant d'énergie
banane a aujourd'hui échoué en europe et
je ne pense pas nécessaire de lui
accorder de la trop de publicité je
trouve que les médias lui ont accordé
énormément de publicité quand il est
arrivé en juin juillet août que la
vérité c'est que c'est un homme très
largement seule pas efficace mais qui
favorise l'idée d'une internationale des
populistes qui pour moi est un problème
parce que le vrai sujet en démocratie
c'est de ne pas avoir un combat entre
les populistes et les progressistes mais
d'avoir différentes options progressiste
ou raisonnable et c'est oui si tout le
monde pense la même chose que des
options différencier c'est à dire que en
vérité si vous regardez si vous regardez
la grave et si vous regardez les
programmes aux élections européennes du
ppe les sociaux démocrates des verts ou
la l2 c'est pas du tout la même chose
la vérité c'est que c'est pas du tout la
même chose et on ne parle pas du tout de
ces différences et elles sont
fondamentales et on ne parle que d'un
conflit imaginaire qui est
essentiellement en france entre des
progressistes et des populistes
ce conflit c'est très bien que ça soit
un grand débat mais c'est un grand débat
français et bien que mais dans ce cas là
qu'est ce qu'il va faire avec les
élections européennes
si on vient de remettre un peu hâtive
parce que revient l'accusation qui est
fait contre l'ensemble national
d'intelligence avec l'ennemi
moi je vais vous dire je vais partir en
prison aussi parce que il ya un mois
nous avons ouvert les colonnes du figaro
magazine et site pilote pour qu'il
développe sa vision de ce populisme
nationaliste
voilà est-ce que pour autant on est des
ennemis de la france et de l'europe
rassurez moi à mon avis ya trois choses
là tant il ya d'abord le mélange des
qualifications juridiques qui m'inquiète
un petit peu il ya la position lors du
rassemblement national alors
intelligence avec l'ennemi c'est plus ou
moins
quelque chose qui nous a servi sous la
troisième république et qui depuis est
resté pour des raisons historiques
évidentes c'est à dire essayer de se
dire que en cas de guerre ou en cas de
conflit on pourrait l'utiliser néanmoins
là le secret je sais trés trés à côté de
ce qui est en train de se passer
néanmoins il ya un autre délit qui est
véritable qui lui est dans le code
électoral c'est qu'un parti politique ne
peut pas se faire financer par un état
étranger hors alors tant qu'il n'est pas
avéré qu steve banane a financé la
campagne des européennes du
rassemblement national a priori pour moi
on est complètement hors des coûts
néanmoins ça vient au deuxième point le
rassemblement national anciennement
front national a fait tous les titres
des journaux depuis 1981 même quand
c'était encore jean marie le pen pour
dire que on l'empêché de s'exprimer et
que donc dès lors que le monde
judiciaire entrer dans ce qui était dit
au rassemblement national il y avait une
atteinte à son pluralité et moi je
crains un petit peu que en faisons cette
commission denquête on nourrissent
encore cet argumentaire de la part du
renseignement national ce qui moi me
gêne un petit peu néanmoins je pense
qu'ils se ridiculisent assez vite tout
seul et que donc ça nous gagne un petit
peu de temps sur le troisième point
c'est l' influence de steve danone cette
influence
vous avez raison je pense qu'il est très
seul il est très seul mais à mon avis il
ne faut pas négliger le fait qu' il est
important que nos parlementaires
français met en lumière le fait qu'on
devrait presque garder comme une
doctrine de philosophie politique on se
mêle de ses affaires intérieures et on
ne peut pas créer des mouvements aussi
large que le populisme européen qu'il
veut essayer de créer hors de ses
frontières parce que tout d'abord on ne
maîtrise pas la politique nationale de
chacun de ces états et je trouve que
c'est une manière de renvoyer le
rassemblement national au fait qu' on se
débrouille avec ses idéologique dans son
état je vous livre le point de vue de
nos internautes
qui donc pas l'air trop inquiet encore
que 62% considèrent qu'il ne faut pas
s'inquiéter des liens entre steve banane
et le rassemblement national ça veut
quand même dire qu'un à 38 % qui pensent
le
contraire quelques commentaires citoyens
payeurs qui pensent ça aussi ça
provoquera peut-être le débat que le pen
et banane c'est du même calibre que
macro et merkel dans une précédente
campagne
ça veut dire une grande proximité
j'imagine voilà je me doutais bien que
guillaume klossa allait réagir eux
babineau nous dit banon est un stratège
il a joué un rôle crucial dans
l'élection de trump il conseille le
rassemblement national
rien de plus alors que hayden estime au
contraire que si steve madden se
rapproche du rassemblement national
cela peut contribuer à déstabiliser
l'europe sébastien pendant votre point
de vue je pense qu'effectivement il faut
pas apporter trop d'importance à stephen
âmes et derrière c'est la question de la
démarche d international dans l'inconnu
bah oui vous qui habitez socialiste bord
et donc pourquoi pas une internationale
populiste pour certains évidemment bon
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on voit
qu'il ya une tentative de fédérer je
dirais un national conservatisme et que
effectivement stephen hunt hand quelque
chose en france on voit aussi par
exemple que marion drache haletante de
fédérer une famille qui n'est pas
exactement celle d'ailleurs dû beaucoup
plus conservatrices donc ce qu'il faut
regarder par rapport à tout ça c'est
doux quel est le sens quelle est la
direction tout ça et on voit bien qu'il
ya cette volonté de commencer à fédérer
toutes les positions toutes les
oppositions notamment à un projet
libéral est en fait c'est une tentative
d' international contre une vision
libérale du monde et l'union européenne
symbolise cette vision libérale du monde
donc aujourd'hui on a quelqu'un qui dit
ok on va revenir sur des blogs qui sont
des blocs puissant nationaux les états
unis d'un côté ça tombe très bien j'ai
aidé donald trump a accédé aux
responsabilités
la russie de l'autre ça me convient très
bien cette union européenne qui se
trouve au milieu dont on a du mal un
petit peu à cerner les contours et c'est
moi je n'en veux pas donc peu importe
steel band moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ce qu'il ya derrière
est ce qu'il ya derrière alors là pour
le coup moi je suis ennemis de ce qu'il
ya derrière
mais pas forcément et demi
siem pour autant face de vous l'avez dit
d'un point de vue du droit c'est un peu
compliqué de tirer les fils de tout ça
si on voit demain qu effectivement leur
assemblée nationale a été financée par
des fonds qui viennent dire ça c'est un
week-end ça c'est interdit pour le reste
voilà est au fond le rassemblent alors
leur assemblée nationale gagnent des
points avec tout ça parce que son
électorat se disent je suis encore plus
conforté que d'habitude
voilà encore une fois on nous attaque en
cause ni l'autre ils montrent quelque
chose que marine le pen a énormément de
mal à prouver qu'il ya quelque chose en
dehors des frontières françaises qui
peut être organisé c'est là où malgré
tout les choses avancent de leur côté
jack g kuzmanovic vous de
l'internationalisme ça vous ça vous
hérisse pas forcément non plus
a priori non mais d'abord juridiquement
ça n'a aucun sens je crois que banny
l'états-unien donc il appartient à ce
pays avec la callas français et alliés
dans l'otan
je sais pas sur quoi lefebvre se bat
c'est exactement ensuite ensuite une
remarque sur le front national je suis
pas le terme de populiste me pose
problème parce qu'il s'applique à
n'importe quoi n'importe qui le front
national revient au front national de
papa avec madden c'est-à-dire très pro
américain c'est la tendance de
de marion maréchal qui fait la même
chose qui est allé là bas qu'ils
rencontrent et manon elle aussi avant
avant sa tante et qui devient très très
lié
ultra libérale c'est l'ancien l'ancien
front national ballond quand même comme
vous l'avez dit défendre les thèses de
thatcher et de reagan
mais ce qu'ils croient pas tandis que
juste qu'ils sont pour la destruction de
l'état et du des services publics ce en
quoi elle s'est illustrée c'est pas très
populiste si le populisme c'est la
défense du peuple et c'est ce que fait
macron d'ailleurs je rappelle que mâcon
il trop et au début de sa présidence
non mais ma croûte migrants banane c'est
la mer jaune en mai macron macro et
ultralibéral il détruit l'état et
détruit la protection sociale la loi la
loi car enfin qui est proposée ou en
parlais tout à l'heure sur la réforme du
de la fonction publique les lustres
assez clairement ils sont plutôt proches
idéologiquement sur ce qu'il faut faire
de l'état et comment ils sont arrivés
plus tôt ils sont algériens c'est un peu
et est sûr c'est que c'est que c'est que
macron au début de sa présidence se
disait amis de deux trains de tram
est-ce qu'on a jugé pour collusion avec
l'ennemi par contre s'il y avait une
vraie colonie qui devrait proposer après
une enquête parlementaire qui était
présidée par les républicains c'est sur
la vente d'un stop on est quand même
dans un pays où la moitié de nos
ministres depuis sarkozy et je vais le
président parce que la vente d'alstom
s'est baladé pas vraiment appliquée
torna et marcal j'ai pris c'était macro
et bien voilà mais c'est la french est
un cas là pour le coup vous pensez qu'il
ya se sont à moitié de nos ministres
font partie d'un think tank la french
american foundation qui trouve des
jeunes deyang leader des jeunes leaders
qui les financent qu'il devienne
ministre
et quand celui ci était conseiller de
monsieur françois hollande il a vendu un
fleuron national qui à alstom et général
electrics rapportant 4,5 milliards à
bank of america à rothschild et à
bouygues et qui vend notre chaudière
nucléaire qui déplace nos sous marins
nucléaires qui assurent notre dissuasion
nucléaire aux états unis s'il y avait
une collusion avec l'ennemi réel plutôt
si je la verrais ici parce qu'elle pose
réellement problème pour la dissuasion
nucléaire notre pays pardon mais pardon
de le dire mais à partir du moment où
les américains sont un allié de l'europe
et qui aidé des fondations des
associations qui promeuvent les
relations entre les leaders peut-être
qu'il faut que quand les gens sont en
cabinet ministériel et puisse pas y
accéder ça ce serait pas anormal parce
qu'en fait mais moi je trouve pas
malsain qui est des programmes d'amitié
avec la chine avec les états unis
et d'ailleurs pourquoi pas avec la
russie trêve moitié de nos ministres
face et par un groupe multi encore ok
mais enfin bon il n'a pas non plus et
puis pourquoi pourquoi macro est quand
même la bête noire donne de banane c'est
à dire que macro il a des qualités il
est vrai qu'il ya des faux mais il a une
vision quand même de l'europe qui est
plus celle d'une europe puissance et
c'est ce que bayonne ne veux pas parce
que c'est pas l'intérêt des états unis
la vérité elle est prête elle est là et
donc macro est la bête noire de bananes
faut le dire et aussi de marine le pen
ce qui tombe bien ça fait effectivement
des alliances objectives